euh vous qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé autour de la table avant qu'on
démarre le débrief euh généralement
après on va revenir bien sûr sur les
tous les points et point par point vous
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé euh moi
j'ai j'ai et je vous DIRIS moi aussi ce
que j'en ai pensé parce que voilà oui
Jean-Michel ouais il y avait pas tout
acheté moi j'ai pas toutcheté en tout
cas parce que j'ai j'ai même appris
certains trucs j'étais crispé au début
de l'émission parce que ils ont
recommencé avec la même technique
journalistique que dans cash
investigation desulcé en disant il a pas
voulu qu'on filme les coulisses
aurait-il des choses à cacher alors ça
c'est le genre d'argument que je déteste
que ça ne veut absolument rien dire
c'est parce que tuouvre pas la porte moi
on sonne parfois chez moi j'ouvre pas
j'ai rien à cacher mais j'ouvre pas
parce que tu as pas toujours envie de de
montrer ce que voilà ce qui ce qui est
le secret d'une entreprise après il y a
d'autres arguments qui étaient
complètement fallacieux comme l'émission
la plus qu' pris le plus d'amende de de
l'histoire forcément c'est l'émission la
plus longue de l'histoire de la
télévision française donc forcément ils
ont plus d'amend que les autres émission
on renir sur tout ça Gén en général mais
autrement voilà j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait des trucs qui étaient qui étaient
vrais voilà tout tout n'était pas
acheter avec le cleau du bain notamment
sur le les les gens qui disent qu'il y a
du stress que vous provoquez vous pouvez
provoquer du stress PARM les salariés de
de votre boîte et cetera oui mais c'est
normal parce que les gens vous voient
comme animateur vous êtes aussi patron
d'une boîte et moi dans toutes les
boîtes où j'étais avant quand je
croisais mon boss comme je foutais déjà
rien et ben je j'enais pas et donc du
coup j'étais stressé que je voyais parce
j'avais peur qu' qu'il m'en metent une
donc c'est normal qu'and a un patron qui
est exigeant parce qu' une émission qui
est très attendue et cetera c'est normal
qu' qu' a une exigence de travail et que
du coup bah les gens ils sont un peu
stressés de savoir s'ils ont bien fait
ou pas donc ça je trouve je vois je sais
pas reproche qui qui est qui est
recevable ça termin en que de poisson
benim vous en bah je te l'ai dit hier
soir je vous l'ai dit pardon hier soir
très honnêtement je trouve que la
montagne a accouché d'une souris quoi
tout ça pour ça euh je pense que les
téléspectateurs qui aiment l'émission
vous connaissent tous les dossiers qui
ont été traités qui ont dans dans dans
le le complément d'enquête vous les
avez-vous déjà abordés dans l'émission
On on peut on pourra les reprendre un
par un mais euh y compris l'histoire de
votre maman y compris sur votre fortune
ici de votre fortune et ca et ca donc
j'ai pas le sentiment que les
téléspectateurs qui connaissent
l'émission et apris quoi que ce soit et
puis ceux qui n'aiment pas l'émission
bah j'imagine qu'ils ont été déçus parce
qu' ils attendaient des trucs très
fantasmés qu'ils n'ont pas eu donc voilà
donc les uns et les autres on j'ai vu
Tristan valex le présentateur quelques
jours avant la diffusion parce qu'il
voulait que je sois dans le fauteuil
rouge forcément bien entendu j'ai pas
j'ai pas accepté parce que je ne
témoigne je fais très peu déjà de télé
et j'en ferai pas pratiquement plus que
j'avais dit déjà au début de l'année ni
de radio et et voilà j'avais pas du tout
envie d'aller dans un fauteuil d'un truc
qui don tout le monde me disait que
c'était à charge et il m'a dit il
m'avait dit Tristan il m'avait dit il
m'a dit
oui je pense que ceux qui pensait qu'on
allait te fracasser vont être déçu mais
il m'a dit on n pas trouvé de compte en
Suisse on n pas trouvé de voilà de
d'histoire de de voà exactement de
dealer ou de choses comme ça donc
forcément N on peut pas on a on a on a
enquêté on a eu ils m'ont dit ils ont eu
énormément de fausses pistes c'estàdire
que des gens racontai n'importe quoi et
ils ont passé énormément de temps et
Virginie VINARD l'enquêtrce a passé
énormément de temps à enquêter sur des
fausses pistes à cause de fausses
rumeurs parce qu'il y en a plein des des
rumeurs incroyables il y avait même une
rumeur comme quoi j'avais acheté pour
500000 € de billets moi je mets pas 50
balles pour acheter des bonbons non mais
c'est gra même cette rumeur qui est
vraiment je sais même pas d'où elle sort
c'està dire que jamais de la vie vous me
connaissez je peux vous dire même mère
euh je si à fait un concert je prends
pas pour 500000 € de place je prends
pour 500 c'est déjà c'est c'est c'est
bien non non mais donc voilà donc je
vous dis il y a eu plein de rumeurs
comme ça il y a eu des rumeurs comme je
sais plus une équipe de bandit bad boy
qui vous suivait tout le temps en
permanence pour comm potes fait non mais
ils sont juste rendu compte sont juste
que c'est mes potes qui sont tout le
temps avec moi et que voilà c'est c'est
voilà et c'est ça il y avait aussi ils
disent que mes fréquentations que je
fréquentais des des des gars qui avaient
fait du placard et cetera que je
fréquentais beaucoup de gens du du Milie
estu années et on est tout le tempsens
Pr c'est pas ex on est juste pote et on
est tout le temps ensemble voilà et donc
voilà donc c'est c'est voilà donc donc
ils ont eu plein de faus p comme ça ce
qui fait qu'ils ont passé beaucoup de
temps également à enquêter sur des
choses éta voilà qui étaai des fauses P
donc ils enquê ils enquêé et Virginie
elle appelé elle appel beaucoup de gens
et à chaque fois elle disait bon bah ça
ça tombe à l'au ça ça tombe à l' ça ça
tombe à l'au et donc à la fin ça a donné
ce complément d'enquête on va revenir
bien sûr point par point dans un instant
sur cette histoire même l'histoire du
bateau sachez que l'histoire du bateau
je vous en parlerai dans un instant mais
elle a été c'était dans le dernier jour
il l'avait pas il l'avait pas le juste
avant ils ont voilà ils ont fait le
bateau le dernier jour ils ont fait le
le bateau ils ont bien fait parce que
c'est c'est j'ai reçu énormément de
propositions pour le racheter
euh et à trèsès à très bon prix si vous
voulez pour les acheteurs on va le
revoir pour qu'il me fasse une
proposition on va on va revoir mon
bateau les chériis regardez je l'ai
donné tout à l'heure à la
voilà 3 million d'euros changé
propositions c'est trois bûches he ça
les chéris qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé je vous donnerai des infos comme
ça tout au long de l'émission he bien
entendu parce que je connais un petit
peu l'ENV du décor et notamment pour le
le fauteuil rouge oui Géraldine alors
moi globalement j'ai été évidemment déçu
comme mes camarades moi je vais pas
revenir sur les points parce que vous
allez revenir sur tous les points j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt décousus j'ai trouvé
qu'il y avait des longueurs je trouvé
qu'il y avait pas de ligne éditoriale
vraiment évident je trouve qu'il y avait
des trucs à dire sur moi j'avais fait un
doc sur vous sur les backstag de de TPMP
je trouvais que voilà en fait on voit
pas vraiment qui vous êtes je trouve que
c'est voilà c'est j'ai trouve ça très
superficiel ça va dans tous les sens
j'ai pas très bien compris et en
revanche il y a un truc qui m'a vraiment
déplu hier j'avais dit le fait qu'on
était vos marionnettes qu'on disait ce
que vous voula dire bon ça ok j'en parle
même plus je radote même plus il y a un
deuxième truc qui m'a déçu et que j'ai
trouvé extrêmement déplacé c'est quand
ils font un micro trottoir devant le
canal Factory ils vont voir les fans Z
ils vont voir les T les spectateurs qui
sont en public d'accord et j'ai trouvé
qu'il y avait un mépris de classe
absolument dégueulasse et parmi les 3
millions de personnes qui on regardaient
hier ben ces gensl ils ont peut-être
regardé documentaires et un
téléspectateur VO un téléspectateurs il
y a pas des bons téléspectateurs et des
mauvais téléspectateurs il y a pas des
bons
électeurs par que c'est grâce à tous les
gens qui me suivent tous les soirs qu'on
a fait un record d'audience hier sur
complément d'enquête quand vous voyez
complément d'enquête la semaine dernière
ils ont fait quoi 600000 600000 et que
cette semaine ils font 3 millions vous
rendez compte c'est grâce à vous je vous
dis et vous le je peux vous dire qu'il
peuvent aussi vous remercier elle éta
dans ouais et ils sont à ces gens-là je
vous
assure regardez ah vous savez quoi on va
on va la mettre la vidéo regardez
regardez on a on a le micro trottoir
regardez ah ben ouais je je mets 2 heur
pour venir ici 2 heur pour venir le voir
en transport en transport ça fait
combien de fois que vous venez ici euh
moi pratiquement tous les jours je viens
tous les jours vous venez presque tous
les jours je viens voir l'émission ouais
et c'est mieux de voir ici que à la télé
ah télé c'est pas la même choseou la
même chose vous avez l'air essoufflé B
on a PE er Laour de la douche et tout
qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu faire ici
ah on est venu se détendre un petit peu
se défouler surtout avec Cyr avec Cyr tu
rentresas cramp tu passes ton temps
rigoler voilà moi j'aime bien parce que
il
déconne il parle de tu
vois mercies chér mer vous dire qu'il
peuvent vous remercier en tout cas parce
que 3 million ce sera leur record ils le
battront jamais de leur vie et le
service public qui donne des leçons et
qui regarde un peu le public avec un
tout petit peu de mépris moi j'ai j'ai
ressenti ça jeà très très déplacé et et
moi sachez que je vous aime et tout le
public qui vient le public qui me
regarde et je vous dis et France
Télévision il devrait vous vous
remercier parce que 3 millions de
téléspectateurs sur un jeudi soir il
l'avaient jamais fait de leur toute leur
vie entière sur France Télévision même
pas même pas compliment d'enquête jamais
de leur vie voilà et c'est grâce à vous
et et je vais vous dire et ils le feront
plus jamais donc voilà donc il PE vous
remercier et vraiment c'est un c'est un
truc c'est un truc incroyable